the flashbang is a core part of
Counterstrike from the memes to some
truly incredible plays oh my God
flash dead but Counter-Strike 2 changed
a lot of things H are better than ever
but flashbangs could be having a sort of
identity crisis fewer flashbangs are
being thrown than just a couple of
months ago and we found a guy with the
numbers to prove it so why are Pros
using flashbangs less and what does it
spell for the future of this iconic nade
I think there's a lot of there's a lot
of uh feeling being done with CS2 right
now because a lot of the analysis hasn't
really been done yet you know we've had
10 years of people doing like deep
analysis of like obscure stuff running
test Workshop maps and for a long time
we haven't had those kind of tools to
test the same kind of
[Applause]
functionality okay folks so before we
get into it I just want to remind you
all to please sub to the channel if you
haven't already and to head over to
shop.com to check out our new merch drop
okay so the flashbang is a venerable
pillar of Counter-Strike flashes have
been in CS since literally the beginning
appearing in some maps in 1.0 and even
in the good old days of 1.6 players were
finding ways to use and abuse their
power to Blind enemies as the years went
on though flashes became more and more
coordinated with people engineering new
obscure angles to catch their opponents
unawares I mean that's going to be a red
flag they should know he's back here but
he's oh my God face to face with am now
flashes offer some very important
utility for a number of reasons one
they're quick properly timed flashes can
catch an enemy off guard and buy you an
important split-second advantage in a
gunfight they're particularly important
for and against oppers and two because
you can carry multiple flashes they have
a little more flexibility than a smoke
one team of kid it out players can
execute some crazy stuff when they dump
utility onto a site this could be the
ticket for aalis these grenades could do
all of the work for them three of them
going over the wall one on exist one on
crims everybody's Catching Fire twist
goes down and there it is they close it
right out two on four in CSG go utility
usage evolved over time driven by back
forth Innovations and one of the
foremost observers of that phenomenon is
Counterstrike analyst Mahone yeah so I'm
Mahone uh you may also know me by my
YouTube channel Mahone TV you may have
also seen me on blast when I did the
Mahone Zone and even before that I was
an analyst for nip Mahone recently
released a great video about the
evolution of utility usage in Inferno
banana and yeah it included some
flashers but we wanted to ask him about
how flashbang usage developed over the
course of csgo because at the beginning
they were pretty simple by the end of it
I think players and teams kind of
understood that to use flashes
effectively you kind of have to be more
precise about them you kind of have to
keep in mind all the cues like whether
the flash balances whether the flash can
be heard like when the player throws it
all these little other things were not
really considered back then but they're
much more considered now but new lineups
with flashes Got Deep to the point where
dodging one by the end could be a
harrowing experience I think the
interesting part about what CS go has
done with the flashbang is just kind of
introduce these sound mechanics
especially when you're on a top team and
you're playing against a team and you're
prepping against them sometimes it's
valuable to know whether you can hear
the flash or not like whether you hear
it bounce off something so that you know
when you're playing upper on nuke when
people are throwing the flashes through
the roof you're going to look out for
whether or not you can actually hear the
flash but if you haven't noticed those
strengths aren't exactly helping flashes
remain relevant in these early days of
CS2 data compile fed by backpack brain
suggests that players are throwing fewer
flashes than ever before so we asked him
about it yeah so I'm backpack brain I
describe myself as a well first and
foremost content creator Rider and
currently with a focus on CS2 the pro
scene especially with my writing as for
outside of that you know I'm studying
and that gives me enough spare time to
focus on that kind of fashion project
all of this started when backpack Rin
noticed something really weird about
team Vitality you may recall that
Vitality recently changed their lineup
with the departure of Magis and addition
of Mesi when asked about replacing him
by play. Apex was clear that some
players are just so unique that directly
replacing them is impossible no one will
replace M know this he's one of if not
the best Anor in the world he has like a
really special role on T side so who on
Vitality was filling the space left by
magisk well that's what our boy backpack
brain wanted to figure out and look
looked at the aggression statistics I
said okay let's put this data in a graph
and I noticed the flashbang usage it
really differed from game to game where
the blast tournaments two of them they
had kind of similar numbers between them
but the csgo tournament was
significantly different and that kind of
got me thinking that's a much more
interesting topic and really there's a
lot more numbers to be looked at across
all other teams across the entirety of
both games of this year and that's what
kind of spad this idea on so refocusing
his article and taking stat from hltv
backpack brain compared flashbang stats
using top 20 landan results from both
CS2 and the end of CSG go and he found
that yeah on average fewer flashbangs
were being thrown by both T and CT with
a slightly larger drop on the tside that
was still true if you looked at all
events and not just Lan now you might be
thinking wait a second the flashbang
itself didn't change in CS2 right it
still costs $200 it still blinds you for
nearly 2 seconds if you're looking right
at it or barely at all if you're looking
away and they can still do this I'm on
HP
I'm what
the so maybe the problem isn't the
flashbang itself but its place in this
new game Counter Strike at the pro level
can be like this intricate puzzle but
plenty of things have been trying to
flip the script lately we've got the
introduction of mr12 and all of the core
responding Economic Consequences of that
which are not necessarily set in stone
but are definitely still being digested
even in 2024 so there's already maybe
one reason right players are so strapped
for cash that they're thinking
flashbangs in this economy but it's not
too hard to think of a lot more the pro
scene itself is undergoing a period of
instability as rosters settle and
competition resumes and as backpack rain
also pointed out isn't it reasonable to
think that newly assembled teams outside
their comfort zones May rely Less on
flashbang heavy executes while they get
things figured out then there's the op
itself which as we recently discussed
has fallen out of favor a
bit oh my god oh is not good remember
flashes are a must against oppers and if
the op itself isn't a must then flashes
aren't either there's also the new
Dynamic smoke and the impact of the H
grenade since the H can now clear smoke
grenades it received added functionality
that competes with flashbangs for your
limited dollars in theory it's possible
that the H grenades added functionality
means that it's more attractive than
before something that was pointed out by
CS Caster tea time in response to the
article with all of these potential
options it's sort of hard to know where
to start so let's throw things over to
Colton and hopefully get a little more
concrete and now the guy who actually
knows what he's talking
about you're really going to lie to
these good people with that transition
when you know I'm about to talk about
Counter Strike I mean who knows at some
point maybe we'll have done enough CS
themed episodes of cracked that it might
be true but I don't even know who I'm
talking to I'm the one editing this
video one of the things that makes
Counter-Strike so unique is its economy
in any given round your team has a
decision to make about how to spend the
resources that you have and those
decisions can mean massive swings in the
game and sure a flashbang is only $200
and that didn't change with CS2 but
plenty of other stuff did in CS2 there
are now only 12 rounds per half a fact
that has made players again re-evaluate
the role of the op it means that each
half is 20% shorter than before so you
have less time to earn and buy guns with
fewer gun rounds losing guns to the
other team is even more significant
really that is an actual balance change
that's changed how the economy works
that's changed how you'd want to
purchase and all you don't want to save
it as much maybe you would rather buy
more rifles for more buy rounds but hold
on a second why are we talking about the
op well in Counter-Strike the oper has
also traditionally thrown a lot of
flashbangs if it backfires and you can't
get it up and running it's it's so hard
that's a flash they line up and he'll
take them both
down the flash
dcon when I think about that I think of
more flashes from teams rather than
players a lot of the time it's just
opers that throw flashes at least in the
more recent C go met up because they're
always in the back and it's hard to
entry and stuff like that they are
typically in a good position to do so
especially since they can Flash others
out of an angle that they then hold
themselves as backpack brains analysis
showed us the reduction in CS2 flashbang
usage was noticeably less dramatic for
opers and well it's hard to know exactly
why it's clear that they remain one of
the primary sources of flashbangs toss
for most teams and so part of what I
suspect is going on with this change and
I don't have 100% guarantee on this but
it seems to check out is that while
generally flashbang usage has gone down
the flashbangs that I used are going to
be more frequently used by the old
recall also that the September 2021
update for csgo allowed players to drop
grenades so opers may throw flashbangs
purchased and dropped by others and
could in a given round throw more than
the two flashbangs you normally allowed
to carry also it means you can try to do
this oh there was think he
turned he turned
now generally speaking counter
terrorists have been struggling more
with the economic impact of mr12 when
you look at the team breakdown both are
throwing fewer flashes but usage
actually drops off even more for the
terrorist team despite that terrorists
aren't fairing much worse in opening
duels actually in this data set they're
doing slightly better and kills pound is
holding steady backpack brains
conclusion at least part of this
phenomenon is terrorists choosing to
take more Peaks without flashes so
that's everything you need to know about
these graphs again big props to backpack
brain for bringing this to the FL and
for speaking with us on an unrelated
note that studio is looking pretty slick
you think maybe sometime I could come in
and record hey wait don't and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so that's the hard data
but what does all this mean for the
future of the flashbang and for your
matches in particular well in terms of
pro play with rosters breaking up and
reforming towards cs2s release including
plenty of igl's on the Move there's
going to be less overall organization
could that also mean fewer flashes
speaking of coordination we've also
recently seen an increase in
international lineups liquid added Caden
as they're oping igl and brought back
twists we've got glaive in charge of a
Polish ends and snappy will be in charge
of the new Falcon roster could these
changes in language mean a longer time
to adapt I think that's going to also
hinder I don't think it's going to
prevent it but I think it's going to
make it take a lot longer than if you
had like every roster speaking their
native language then you'd be able to
get up to speed on the small stuff like
team Synergy much quicker and then you'd
already be able to talk about utility
and improving the overall level of the
game so that's one aspect which I didn't
talk about cuz you can analyze that but
I think it's important to discuss it and
while the flash itself didn't receive
any direct changes two other nades did
the H and the smoke now smoke clouds can
be popped from distance offering players
a shining opportunity to Peak and kill
but honestly it's sort of difficult to
gauge clearing smokes with h grenades
just isn't that common right now in Pro
play but it is something that we could
see more of as things are figured out
and rosters become more cohesive I you
want to get close yeah Nate Rob can you
FL oh G if I were to speculate a little
bit I feel that in the future
H grenades are going to be used more for
anti- strting like it's just say you
know that a team always throws this
particular smoke beforehand you're going
to say you know what we're going to make
sure to always have a nade so that we
blow up that smoke and take advantage of
it it really depends on what the other
team does I feel like that's where it
should be heading cuz I think over time
or rather right now it feels kind of
like if you're just going to buy an H
just to wait for that particular
opportunity to come up it may not come
up as for you at home this doesn't mean
that you should suddenly stop buying FL
fles when your team needs them learn
your lineups seriously but it does mean
that you should be considering the
impact of buying a flash over a more
versatile tool especially in the face of
weaker oping that said part of backpack
brain's data suggests that uncoordinated
rosters do get a little bit less value
out of a flashbang and let's be honest
your face at pugs probably not that
coordinated so if you're stuck choosing
maybe just buy a smoke instead after all
in Pro play the lower levels of flashes
and Ops could make the game a little
scrappier and more about Gunplay which
could bring these two vastly different
levels of play a teeny tiny bit closer
to each other and hey if the economy
stays this rough for CTS for the
foreseeable future it's possible we
could see Pro tside flashbang usage
rebound but not the CT side or not as
much I think it's going to be near the
end of this year maybe the second major
you stuff to see the statistics kind of
level out compared to what they used to
be and then coming 2020 five you're
going to really see the Renaissance of
utility Innovation I think this year
we're just going to build the teams and
we're going to get CS2 like figured out
so are flashes suddenly on the way out
well no obviously not but for the
foreseeable future we could see them
become a little less overly relied on
than before and hey flashes could return
to dominance one day but until then
we'll always have the
memories spash bag how was that good
impression of who of the Cs guy who used
to say that [__] what CS guy you know
the thing in the game like the bomb oh
like the character flashbang flashing
out flashing out I really hope we were
cutting I really hope we caught that on
the
mic